be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so because I'm going insane by making
the same contrived videos on comic book
characters and teams I've decided to
change things up a bit and experiment
with a segment where I just rant about
things this is everything that I think
is wrong with Marvel Comics right now so
all-new all-different level launched
almost a year ago and you know what I'm
waiting for all-new all-different marvel
for those of you guys who were just now
getting into comics if you were reading
the various websites around the internet
devoted to geek culture in the months
prior to its launch only while different
Marvel was being touted as a reboot on
every page and in every speculation
video sure
Marvel never actually came out and said
reboot but I don't think it's
unreasonable for existing and potential
fans to perceive this idea why because
of the words new and different looking
at Webster's dictionary new is defined
is not existing before made introduced
or discovered recently or now for the
first time different is defined is not
the same as another or each other unlike
in nature form or quality putting these
terms together we get something that
hasn't existed before and is not the
same as something else
considering that all-new all-different
marvel was coming out of Jonathan
Hickman's time runs out which detailed
the collapse of the multiverse leading
into secret Wars which ended with Reed
Richards Franklin Richards in molecule
man recreating the multiverse it seems
reasonable to believe that all-new
all-different marvel was being built as
a concept designed to reboot the
entirety of its lineup in favor of
something that hadn't existed before and
by extension hadn't been seen before the
problem with this is that there's
nothing all new or all different about
Marvel Comics case in point
amazing spider-man this is Marvel's
flagship spider-man title it focuses on
the life of Peter Parker who exists as
the head of parker industries and is one
of the richest men in the world
rounding out the title come see lists
villain turn see list hero Hobie Brown
who acts out the role of spider-man
whenever Peter Parker is not available
max Modell who's the former head of
horizon labs and inspiration for Peter
Parker and a Marconi a brill
woman with a diminutive stature who
operates as one of Peter Parker's best
employees and advisors and Doctor
Octopus who resides within a robot's
body now if you're reading comics for
the very first time this is likely as
new to you as any comic being picked up
by anyone who had never read that
particular comic before but you may also
find yourself asking questions like why
is dr. octopus in a robot's body why is
max no Dowlen inspiration for Peter
Parker what is Parker industries and
where did it come from to answer this we
have to jump back before the launch of
all-new all-different marvel and read
superior spider-man which literally
introduced all of these characters for
the first time instead of being all new
we're all different the stories continue
on from before Secret Wars as if nothing
had happened and this is not the only
title like this Carol Danvers was
knocking boots with James Rhodes in the
enemy within storyline from Captain
Marvel volume 8 before Secret Wars which
explains why she was so upset about him
dying in the lead-up to Civil War 2
Thanos was thought to have been killed
off during Secret Wars by Doctor Doom
but was actually hanging out in the
space outside of the multiverse
apparently haven't been recreated by
Reed Richards and the conversation
between Galactus and molecule man even
goes as far as to voice Marvel's thought
process that maybe it's a reboot maybe
it's not the world of comics draws its
inspiration and success from two
distinct factors relate ability and
consistency in 2012
valya comics reintroduce faith to their
comic landscape as an overweight woman
with the power of flight sure she got
flack for the premise but faith as a
character was rooted in the idea of
empowering men and women who had been
made to feel inadequate over the course
of their lives based on any number of
factors including their size their
intelligence or the demeanor
conversely Marvel fans growing up in the
1990s love the x-men animated series
because it had great stories but also
serve as an easily accessible means a
segue into the otherwise confusing comic
landscape at the time the popularity of
Jubilee as a representation of fans
within the x-men universe serve to
increase the popularity of the
Generation X title and the x-men stories
under Claremont and Gimli were pushed to
greater heights by way of the TV show
the mutants of Marvel Comics operated as
comic-book stand-ins for the struggle
against all forms of oppression and the
idea that the only way to keep the world
from descending into chaos
was to corner Anish and fight for your
bit of sanity kids who were picked on
and ridicule could find solace and the
stories of Captain America leading the
mighty battle against some overpowering
enemy and finding a way to win in the
face of almost guaranteed defeat these
small bits came together as a greater
whole and were maintained through their
consistency yes there were bad stories
and villains like Eunice the untouchable
were silly because he suffocated inside
of his own forcefield but the good
outweighed the bad by leaps and bounds
for every terrible villain and in a
ridiculous plot you had stories like
Peter David's incredible hope which
focused on banners relationship with his
father and the abuse that banner
suffered as a child which was the
underlying current of why the Incredible
Hulk persona manifested after the gamma
bomb explosion in the first place for
every in continuity story you had out of
continuity stories like Wolverine kills
the Marvel Universe where he's
brainwashed by Hydra in the hand didn't
goes on a killing spree wiping out every
single hero in existence I don't know if
it's a byproduct of changing markets or
because the success of the MCU has led
to the image run in the
but the comic-book arm of Marvel
Entertainment has lost the relatability
inconsistency factors instead of
focusing on good storytelling
with a smaller number of titles Marvel
is now assembly lining their productions
at a rate that boggles the mind in 2004
a man named Barry Schwartz released a
book called the paradox of choice why
less is more and detailed the
psychological principle that if people
are presented with 50 options they're
less likely to actually choose anything
but if they're presented with five
options the decision becomes easier now
I'm not advocating that mob will reduce
their publications to a total of five
that would be silly and would lead to
insane profit losses but the problem
with throwing out so many publications
over such a short amount of time without
providing any measure of ongoing
consistency continuity or relatability
means that the comics themselves are
released measured found watching and
cancelled before people even have a
chance to understand what's going on a
perfect example of this is Al Ewing's
ultimate right now the comic is selling
20,000 issues a month is on the border
of being cancelled and what's worse it's
the best Marvel title you've never heard
of if you find yourself wandering around
asking how the new universe relates to
the old one Ultimates will answer that
if you're curious about whether or not
the cosmic entity still exists Ultimates
answers that the problem is that with
the exception of the participation in
the battle against an extra dimensional
celestial at the beginning of civil war
- there's no mention of any kind about
their place in the larger universe
without being said this is my two cents
this is my little rant let me know what
you guys think I'll catch you guys later
peace